and what has this BLM grifter mindset
actually done to Once Great American
cities as I said it destroyed them
criminals walk into stores taking
whatever they want it's their right
after all it's consumer reparation some
say
well what's worse is our society is
allowing this some say even encouraging
it monsters are assaulting robbing even
murdering now in broad daylight
sounded like a repetitive like boom boom
boom boom when officers arrived they
found two gunshot victims a 37 year old
man and a 34 year old pregnant woman
inside this Tesla
and the ultimate grift is that these
cities are now full of squatters and
it's getting dangerous my next guest is
an la-based residential developer and he
says that for the last few years he's
been dealing with these people squatting
inside some of his vacant properties
it's led him to call police more than 90
times
was there anybody upstairs
are you sure okay because we're gonna
start
you'll be arrested for trespass from
here on out
they're going to board it up that's why
they're here
[Music]
all well and good but the squatters
guess what they kept coming back the
developer then hired a private security
team that's what it's come to to remove
them when this happened
yeah they decided to burn that sucker
down joining me now Brandon Hance
co-founder and CEO of Avenue homes
Brandon that was obviously one of your
properties burning to the ground is that
the only one
unfortunately it's not there were three
others within a few blocks of that
property
so because you dared to bring your own
security team in to put an end to the
fact that strangers were breaking into
your homes uh living there and demanding
not to leave you've actually had them
removed and that was the response
that's right you know we started with
the obvious solution call the cops uh
their hands were tied and said listen
there's nothing we could do we hired
employees the employees were overwhelmed
so we had to literally hire Israeli
Defense Forces to come in fully armed
just to keep our property safe and you
see here on the footage they're trying
to do that but there's only so much you
can do and at the end of the day four of
the properties fell victim to arson and
now we're left literally in scraps
now mayor Karen bass in La
um you know just recently elected
addressed this homelessness in the city
watch
40 000 people on the street is a crisis
it's an emergency the way angelino's
experience homelessness is encampments
whether you are in an encampment or live
near one or work near one or drive by
one that is how angelino's experience uh
homelessness and making that the first
order of business
you're not a vagrant you're experiencing
homelessness
um have you seen this squatter problem
get worse or better now that she's
really tackling this homeless problem
well I will say the encampments have
certainly improved but the question is
where are they going I think we've
experienced part of the answers they're
coming into our properties so in one
hand it's benefiting the community on
the other hand it's causing you know an
equivalent amount of damage elsewhere
so Brandon my question you as an
investor someone who's putting a lot of
your personal Capital investors capital
on the line
why are you doing it I mean everyone's
going to Florida or Nevada or or
Tennessee or Alabama or Mississippi or
Florida why are you putting up with this
I'll tell you there's a question I hear
all the time and it's a legitimate
question I was born and raised in La I
went to college in La I'm raising three
daughters in L.A this is where we are we
believe in the city unfortunately we
just have failed leadership and broken
policies so hopefully we can be a part
of a solution I'm not terribly
optimistic at this point but we're going
to continue to fight the good fight
well Brandon at some point you have to
save yourself right I mean this has gone
on year after year after year and the
people had a chance to make a change and
they elected Karen bass I mean I'm glad
some of the encampments have broken up
but I mean I I have friends that have
told similar stories to you about cars
being set on fire in really expensive
neighborhoods and the police basically
say was anyone hurt no it's just the
cars and Flames we'll call the fire
department and you know good luck that's
just what that's just what's happening
these days so God bless you and I hope
there can be political change but
meanwhile you know you're holding the
bag on a lot of these Investments
Brandon thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else